now the first question I'm going to post
before we turn to segue into this is how
do we measure angles how do we measure
angles what what units do we use okay we
measure angles in degrees
okay now angles are battling rotation
okay retention so we have how many
degrees in one full rotation once the
revolution how many 360 okay
now my question is why are there 360
degrees degrees in a revolution it's a
fantastic question it's one of the first
question mark it's one of the first
questions that gets posed as soon as
students learn what degrees are okay why
360 degrees yeah because they need 360
degrees you've been dying to chop
someone's head okay well it's a violent
reason to side historically historically
there are two reasons why we have chosen
360 degrees in a revolution okay the
first reason has to do with the
Babylonians and their number system we
have own we have base ten base then the
Babylonians had base 60 okay no but it's
like oh yeah because they had like I
don't know I'm slightly sorry why 60 and
why they for 360 okay and the reason why
is because when you have something
that's as round right and people have
been using round things to tell the time
for well a long time because time itself
is in a cyclical making it ran around
enough so circles 60s 360s they make
sense to put together because they're
easy to define right 360 divides into
right now if we think of the factors of
360 just think about this for a second
right divides into what obviously it
divides everything divides
no big deal it's an even number so it
divides into two keep going with it how
many other dunamis imagine if you spent
three
it goes into four four 9s it goes into
five it goes into six doesn't go into 7
because 7 is a punk right but it goes
into it goes into 8 it goes in tonight
it goes into 10 I could keep going right
it goes into 12 and 15 and 18 but just
look at that it divides into 9 of the
first 10 numbers right that's really
useful right if you want to divide
something up it helps to stay and not
hold on the world right so you make your
number sufficiently large such that you
see if you stay at 60 I think you miss
out you miss out eight nine now you get
the rest of them but now that's pretty
cool right so 360 divided into those
easily so factorization works well okay
that is the first reason we say 360
degrees in a circle but in a revolution
there's another reason it's probably the
more important one historically and that
is sailors today Liz now what do you say
Liz have to do with measuring angles I
would tell you right imagine you're a
sailor and you're out in port okay it's
beautiful now you're out in the middle
of the ocean okay
and you're trying to make sure you can
get from A to B now today I'm um as it
happens I'm going to be driving through
st. Myers off to school I didn't drive
to st. Ives very often okay so in order
you get to say nice because I don't have
it like right up here what do I do
how do I get I I could use GPS what's my
GPS gonna tell me right cuz it's not
gonna self Drive my car at least not yes
right it's gonna give me directions it's
gonna give me like landmarks and names
roads and like take a left here and the
right bear etc right now you're a sailor
and you're out in the middle of the
ocean there are no road signs there are
no landmarks this is just water right
so how do you say this work out with it
oh they look up look us now and let's
draw just for the sake of it
there you go you recognize that one
right hopefully ok now this is actually
not that bad because you've got um if
you didn't know one of the ways you can
know which cross because there's a few
crosses in the sky but one of the ways
you can do which one's the Southern
Cross is that um the two brightest
objects apart from Venus if it's up
Alfred medicine teri and they point to
the Southern Cross there's a few false
crosses are everywhere um you look up
and you look at a stars now here is the
important thing you need to get stars
are really great stars are really good
because they don't really move very fast
they're kind of you know constant except
for the fact that they're not right
because he's the son and he's easy this
is the worst to scale diagram Emma okay
but just just go with no when you are
looking at the night sky okay when
you're looking at the night sky which
side of the earth are you on now in my
diagram you're on the right side aren't
you like because this side has day and
this side has nine okay so what's
happening is you're looking at a
particular part of the night sky the
putt that you would see this way you
can't see any of these stars because
they're they hidden by the Sun and
you're on the locusts on the planet okay
but you can see I'm not always going to
be looking around here because we're not
stationary with your dog to the Sun
right we're moving around the Sun we are
orbiting so we orbit like so okay now
let's just think about this for example
if you go about three months
three months later okay where am I going
to be roughly and the answer is I'm
going to be like roughly here right now
what's three months of person I'm over
there like the planets over there
and you think about who's looking at the
night sky which side of the planet is
looking for night sky and on my diagram
beyond the topside is looking at okay
but you can clearly see at that point in
time you're looking at a completely
different portion of the night sky
versus at this point in time right and
over here and you're looking at
different portion and here you're
looking a different portion right so the
night sky despite when you look at it
it's not living it actually is moving
all the time just you know it takes this
amount of time about 360 days to go all
the way around and then you're back more
or less to a started and you'll see the
same configuration of stars right okay
now sailors pretty bright Bunch
okay in fact sail is one of the first
people to do is quite significant
mathematics because the mathematics of
astronomy is quite they realized okay
look you know I've been saving for years
right and every 360 days every day I'm
getting the same set of stars right
clearly what's going on is something
like rotation okay do you see why it has
to be rotation like if you looked out
the window if you were driving and you
like you to put your little kid and you
got like a little road trip okay you
look out the window and you see some
portion of road okay okay that's that's
something else and then you keep driving
and then you see a different portion of
road and every time you look out you see
something different now that would make
sense if what you were doing was moving
in a straight line if you're moving a
straight line every time you look you'll
see something different but if there's a
cyclic nature of things then rotation
must be the conclusion right you have to
be retaining around something and that's
why you return back to the same portion
of the night sky about every 306
days so in other words what were the two
reasons for why we came to measure
rotation in this particular unit and the
answer is number one convenience
convenient like it's really really
convenient to divide up 360 but secondly
well it's a coincidence right we're the
only planet in the solar system that
takes roughly 360 rotations around our
axis to go around the Sun okay does that
make sense
like when we're comparing like 360 days
around the around the Sun in here means
this thing rotates 360 times every time
it goes once around it's completely a
coincidence and if you came aboard of
different planets right we would all
come up with a different measurement
because the sailors would be like well
it doesn't take 360 rotations to get me
but it takes like 85 or 100 and you know
whatever number okay so convenience and
coincidence what I'm trying to get at is
there's no inherently mathematical thing
the mathematical property about 360 that
makes degrees the best measurement for
angles okay there's no inherently
mathematical property of breaking up the
revolution into 360 degrees that makes
it a better choice than anything else it
is more or less arbitrary right but it's
a system that we've been working as we
deal with further maths right and today
will be the first instance that we do it
and next year when we look at the
calculus of trigonometric functions we
will discover even more degrees are
completely inadequate in completely not
occur so then the question becomes what
do you use instead